we knew that Donald Trump would become
wacky and erratic and even more unhinged
after his impeachment acquittal and it's
happening and it's happening very very
quickly in a cartoonish sense
Donald Trump has been repeatedly
tweeting this joke video about remaining
president for twenty years that's on the
cartoonish side on the serious
authoritarian side Donald Trump is now
purging impeachment witnesses who just
did what they had to do they showed up
they answered questions they told as far
as we can tell the truth under oath
under penalty of perjury about what they
knew during the house impeachment
inquiry and Trump is now firing them
Donald Trump has fired Lieutenant
Colonel Alexander VIN Minh he has fired
ambassador to the European Union
Gordon Sunland he does not care he is an
authoritarian he is acting like an
authoritarian and he will probably get
away with it in all likelihood Sandlin
said in a statement on Friday night
quote I was advised today that the
president intends to recall me effective
immediately
as United States ambassador to the
European Union now both of these firings
Finland and Sunland are wacky for
different reasons first you have
Lieutenant Colonel bin Minh
lieutenant-colonel as in a member of the
military Donald Trump and his side claim
to support and believe in and respect
and revere the troops and see them as
trustworthy not when they show up and
tell the truth about Donald Trump
apparently and now Lieutenant Colonel
VIN Minh is seen instead of some kind of
untrustworthy sort of Ukrainian hack who
cannot be trusted or believed or
employed Gordon Sunland on the other
hand remember is a major donor to Donald
Trump Gordon Sunland effectively bought
an ambassadorship this is actually
something you can do if you donate a lot
of money and Gordon Sunland donated
about a million dollars to Donald
Trump's inauguration and he bought
himself an ambassadorship was a big
Trump supporter and again Trump fired
him because he showed up and told the
truth under oath under penalty of
perjury and Trump is furious about that
if you are surprised
that Donald Trump is doing this you've
not been paying attention because Donald
Trump has publicly said his entire
presidency and even more lately that his
style is that of authoritarians he's
eluded to dealing with traitors like
they did in the old days he's talking
about hanging traitors of course also
referring to people who aren't traitors
as traitors like the whistleblower he's
talked about how much he loves Rodrigo
Duterte handling of the war on drugs
which includes just extrajudicial
killings in the street of not only drug
suspected drug dealers but even drug
users and meanwhile Trump is less
inclined to behave like our Western
allies whether it's the UK Germany
France and all of the other countries
that you probably have heard me list
before in this context so should we
really be surprised when the news broke
that Trump has an enemies list and Mitt
Romney's on the list and Adam Schiff is
on the list and Jerry Nadler and then
now he fires impeachment witnesses of
course we shouldn't be surprised we have
an authoritarian in the White House at
the beginning of his presidency he was
only using authoritarian ish language
now he is actually behaving like the
authoritarian that he wants to be and of
course this is going to be the last
straw right I mean now all of these
Liberty loving righties are going enough
of course not we vote on November 3rd of
2020 that's the one opportunity we have
to hold Donald Trump accountable and
sadly there is nothing else I told you
when Donald Trump was acquitted last
week on impeachment and in fact I told
you before because we knew he was going
to be acquitted he is going to scale up
he is going to become more erratic he is
going to become more authoritarian he is
going to be reinvigorated by the reality
he's accurately understanding whatever
the hell I do I get away with ok sure
some of my old friends went to prison
but he doesn't care about that this is
merely the beginning just wait until you
see what this guy is going to do between
now and the November election and if he
wins re-election all bets are off
about what a Trump second term is going
to look like
I want to tell you about one of our
sponsors magic spoon remember breakfast
cereal when I was growing up breakfast
cereal was a really big part of my
Saturday mornings then I became an adult
and realized I don't want to be eating
all that sugar I don't want to be eating
all that junk and now breakfast has
gotten much more boring magic spoon is a
new cereal company that has discovered
how to recreate your favorite childhood
cereals with zero sugar twelve grams of
protein and just three grams of net
carbs per serving they offer four
flavors based on the classics cocoa
fruity frosted and blueberry plus the
variety pack which lets you try them all
magic spoon spent more than a year
working with the best food scientists
and chefs to recreate the taste and
texture of that classic sugary cereal
but it tastes so incredible you would
never guess that it was healthy its keto
friendly gluten free grain free soy free
low carb and GMO free you've got to try
it to believe it because it tastes great
my favorite of course cocoa cocoa go to
magic spoon comm slash Pakman grab a
variety pack and try it today make sure
to use the promo code Pakman at checkout
to get free shipping magic spoon is so
confident in their product it is backed
with a 100% happiness guarantee if you
don't like it for any reason you'll get
a refund no questions asked that's magic
spoon dot-com slash Pakman promo code
Pakman for shipping